hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the final round of the
creation Grantchester being played in
Zagreb it's a Yanni Pony vs. onigiri
we've only shown one game from the final
round so far Magnus Carlsen versus
maxima sherrilyn Grove and we said that
we were gonna show at least one more so
we can cover the standings and talk a
little bit more about what just happened
here so here we have a nice photo of
this matchup there this courtesy of
Lennart oldest official photographer of
the grand chester so let's just enjoy it
therefore again rocking his men bond as
you can see there so without further ado
let's just check it out nipple wood
white piece is opened with e4 with c5 by
giri Knight to f3 and d6 and here Bishop
to b5 check so nipple goes for the canal
attack with Knight to d7 and now c3
preparing d4 here we have Knight to f6
attacking the e4 pawn and now although
Quinta e 2 is the the main line here
with Bishop back to d3 I'm not sure well
a much rarer play play in line the idea
is now we want to retreat the bishop
over to see - before you make this
central thrust that is d4 so g6 gira
continuous development prepares the
Finca to the dark square brush up the c2
by nepo Bishop to g7 and only now d4 we
have castles bye-bye Geary castles by
Neto and here there are a few attempts
here in this position one is C capture
some before before are dealing with
White's attempt to push a 5 or just the
Queen to c7 one such example is Levin
Ireland vs. summons your ego in 2018
world's blitz worldlets champion Jim
where Queen to c7 was played with the
idea of preventing White's
efj I've but Levin was successful in
winning that game but here we have b5
and it's a new move by Geary it was not
played before and the giver basically
says here that he doesn't even care
about ephod that a 5 is not a real
threat
so here neppo really had to see what was
going on i don't know if nipple had this
position in his home preparation or that
his team covered is for him so he knew
what to play
he pushed 'if I've as the black did
nothing to prevent it so we have E 5
here and tau Giri does not react to it
he just plays Knight back to e it's now
the bishop also attacks e 5 so you have
to do something about it but Knepper
says ok no problem d 6 now your knight
is under attack and I'm threatening to
capture on f7 but it's also a pawn
sacrifice so Geary accepts it with F
captures only 6 and now Knight to g5 so
the threat is Knight captures on e6
where you would win material as both the
Queen and the rook would be under attack
so you have to defend it you can defend
it would work to have six or the move
gear replaced with nice to see 7 now the
night from c7 guards e6
and now first D captures and c5 with
Knight captures on c5 and here's where
you really have to think about what
you're gonna do and this is this
position is what this game is all about
and the Naples next move really it's
just wonderful here if you put this
position into an engine it really all
depends on the engine if you have a
weaker engine then you will get one idea
if you have a stronger engine you will
have another idea alpha zero will
probably have a completely different
idea but never had an idea that pretty
much everyone would play in a in a
bullet game let's say or maybe even in a
blaze game but neppo actually went for
Knight captures on h7 and it seems like
a beautiful idea you just win a pawn
you're threatening to win the rook if
King captures you have Queen to h5 check
as of course the pond will not be able
to capture as its pinned but give you
just you know captures the knight on h7
and he does it in cold blood if if I do
say so myself
King captures on h7 with Queen to h5
check by neppo King has to go back King
to g8 and now Bishop captures on g6 so
an F never sacrificed a piece for - very
nice pawns and now he's threatening
Queen to h7 checkmate so there is only
one move that prevents mate and that is
rook to f6 you have to make some room
for a king on f8 but now never continues
Queen to h7 check with King to f8 and
now how do you proceed here you have to
try something
so neppo continues the attack would be
up to h6 and again it comes with a
threat rook Queen captures here will be
checked
made so the only good move will not be
only good move the only move Giri has in
this position is rook captures and g6
you have to give back some material but
it's not a problem as white already
sacrificed a piece so you're basically
just giving a rook for four to pieces
and now here's the position that maybe
nepos saw when he sacrificed on either
Nate 7 maybe he didn't maybe he just
thought the attack was well straight out
overwhelming but here you have to decide
do you capture the rook or do you play
Queen tha to check and queen to hhx
seems well just winning as you can't
capture of course the bishop is pinned
and after you move the King black will
lose the Queen and also it comes with an
attack on tonight so there doesn't seem
to be anything wrong with this but as
usual in chess there is always most of
the times something wrong with it so
here if nipple did play Queen to h8
check you would get King to f7 Queen
captures on d8 now with an attack on the
night but it's not a problem because
here black has the wonderful resource
rook captures ng to check where white
can react in two ways either capture the
rook or move the King if you capture the
rook then you get Bishop e7 check now
you have to react to this rook captures
Queen now black recaptures the Queen and
after lights a bishop capture some g17
captures when you count the pieces White
has two rooks and the knight but black
has a rook two knights and a bishop so
basically you have a bishop and the
night for a rook but with the monster
Bishop and b7 blacks position is just so
much better that the white will not be
able to even play this on the other hand
if you don't do this for example if you
after rook captures and GG you don't
capture your other option is king - h1
but it's still not any better just rook
to g6 now again with the threat of
Bishop e7 check and picking up the Queen
so now Queen captures on c7 Bishop
captures on h6 and now whatever you play
doesn't really matter because white it
doesn't have a good move Bishop the b7
check is coming you cannot develop the
knight the bishop covers d2 you can't
really go g1 as Bishop to b7 just wins
so you can't really develop anything you
can try something like a 4 but then
there should be seven check you get F
three and then just rook a to g8 with
the threat of Ruby g1 check and there's
nothing to do here whatever you play
let's say night a3 rook g1 is coming and
it's game over
rook captures an out Bishop captures an
f3 with Czech rubgy - Bishop captures
and g2 check King g1 and now Bishop to
e3 will be checkmate as there's nothing
well no no squares left for the White
King so after rook captures and g6 neppo
thought about the position for for some
time but in the end he saw that Queen to
h8 doesn't do anything for white so he
had to capture the rook we have Queen
captures in g6 Bishop captures on h6
Queen captures on h6 and now King te 8
and now Gary's ready to tuck his King to
safety here on d7 play Bishop to b7
developed the monster light-square
bishop and then well after this rook
enters the game it's it's gonna be very
hard for white so what can nepo do in
this position well for starters he can
start developing his pieces and also he
does have two connected passed points on
the Kings side if you know he can
somehow get them rolling but it will be
very difficult here will be 4 by neppo
attacking the knight Knight to a4 and
our just nice the a3 preparing c4
preparing to open up the position
somehow you cannot capture on c3 as
quint h8 check will just pick up the
night so it's not not an issue King to
d7 by giri and now c4 and okay be
captures and c4 beg and by Gary Knight
captures on c4 and now just Bishop to a6
you wanna now start developing pieces as
soon as possible we have rook a to C 1
and now Knight the b6 of course you
don't want to give up your monster light
score goes up so if you want to trade
you want to trade with the night we have
Knight captures and b6 black had to
challenge this night before developing
the rook or something because it's a
very dangerous night you could play
something like rook e1 get the night
over here maybe with check and you don't
want to complicate things as you're up
in material you want to trade down so
Knight b6 challenging the knight Knight
captures with a capture some b6 and now
just look after a 1 getting the rock out
of harm's way
but now Bishop back to b7 now Gary's
bishop assumes this beautiful diagonal
that what can what can you do here never
go squinty III creates an attack against
the b6 pawn here and perhaps maybe maybe
just maybe he can start pushing his H
pawn with b5 I'm getting the pawn out of
harm's way but also preparing this
blockade with Bishop to d5 and Bishop to
c4 so white will not be able to use the
open C file for any sort of an attack
with a 3 as the a 2 point was a target
now Bishop to d5 also the bishop now
guards the pawn here so now the knight
can enter the game
we've looked the c3 preparing to double
up rooks and the C file but now Queen to
g8 now this comes with the threat of
checkmate so you have to defend we have
Queen to h3 by nipple and now Queen to
g7 putting pressure on the rook here the
White Queen is unable to move from the
3rd rank now rook eat the c1 doubling up
on the C file nipple now threatens to
capture on c7 but now it's not an issue
Bishop to c4 as the b-pawn prepared this
move
well after after a nipple attacked it
with Queen to e3 we look back to e1 as
the C file is now permanently closed and
now what do you do here rook to e1 it's
not really there there are no threats
here even though nipple is does cover
some some files and some some squares
here now but you could blunder for
example if you try something like
Knights - eh - gate denied to get the
knight into the game for example now
rook captures and c4 would allow you to
capture on e6 something like this
captures captures and then you can
capture on c4 and maybe you can create
some counter play Brooks you want with
the threat of checkmate and maybe you
could survive this but of course Gary
not interested in allowing such such
ideas just Queen to d4 now the Queen
also defends the bishop here so any
captures will be met with Queen captures
the Queen also guards the e6 square and
now the knight can finally enter the
game with rook to f3 by white and now
Queen to d2 with an attack on the rook
here route back to b1 and now Knight to
d5 now the old that's left for Gary is
to bring the handle a stroke into the
game with Queen to g3 and now how do you
proceed here well Gary just played
Bishop 2
to a very nice attack on the rook the
rook on f3 you don't really have a good
square to put the rook here rook F the
b3 was played at least the rooks are now
guarding each other but here Giri just
found the quickest way to win and well
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this very nice idea I'll give you a
couple of seconds a photo zoo who were
able to do it there are a lot of winning
ideas like rook to a rook the c8 is
winning but the most enjoyable one is of
course Bishop to d1 so if you found it
congratulations you are an excellent
player now there's nothing to do here
anymore you either lose more material
you cannot go look to e3
as the night covers d3 square and well
you cannot protect a defend against both
threats Bishop captures here and Queen
t1 is checkmate of course so as the
bishop now blocks the rogues defense of
the last rank so that's what happened
here and that was a very amazed with
Gary's interview after the game Gary
just said that what happened in this
game was that giri was just much better
prepared for this game that he prepared
with a better computer and that
Nepos team probably at some point found
that the this was playable for white
even though they did not cover actually
sacrificing the night on h7 they said
that White's position was was fine even
even if it's a new line that b5 moved at
Aguirre played but neppo just thought
that this was working for him as I don't
know he just didn't cover it in you know
within up enough depth at home and gear
just knew that the attack was was not
working so it wasn't really an issue for
him he played it very fast and he
defended very correctly he said that he
just had to remember that the precise
order of the moves how to defend but
everything was pretty much forced so it
wasn't really an issue so really amazing
game I used the title F for frustration
as this is what neppo tweeted after this
game as he really had a beautiful start
to the tournament three wins out of
those three wins two with the black
piece and then he just lost the ding
then lost the course and then lost this
game to Gary a lot of losses you know
will will nullify the other ones you had
at the start of the turn
so here so I don't forget I promised you
the standings after you eleven rounds of
the creation Grantchester here they are
Magnus Carlsen so lead with eight out of
eleven then Wesley so with seven clear
second then Fabiana Curran 11 Oregon
with six with then we have three people
with five and a half
dinkler and onigiri and Jana pond she
with five Sergey Carrick in four and a
half with Maxine buffalo grove shafter
mom in Europe and Vishwanathan Anand and
in last place he Cara Nakamura this
definitely was not his tournament and
also a lot we said that I misspoke in
the previous video where I said Magnus
did not return to his former glory as he
still didn't reach his former rating I
don't know there's sometimes you will I
will have a different information
you know regarding where I look for it
so most of you are probably checking out
to the information on the chest I don't
know it's a twenty to twenty seven
hundred chess website there are much
faster at updating their rating than the
official feed a website so here is
something I prepared these are the
highest ever achieved ratings so far so
Carson as you can see achieved for
twenty eight hundred and eighty nine
point two in 21st of April 2014 and at
the moment he's very close to that and
well if you check out the live ratings
it seems that he will cross twenty-eight
hundred and ninety with the first of the
next month when the rating you know
comes it comes into play as the rating
changes on the first of every month so
it seems that Magnus will already have
reached his new high score but some of
you are saying that he needs one more
win in a classical time format to do it
so really not sure I will have to check
once again but just you know he is very
close I will say that but also this is a
very nice very nice you know highest
ever rating stable if you're interested
here you can see that Kasparov reached
twenty eight hundred fifty six point
seven on 3rd of March 2000 which is
extremely impressive I mean it was a
much harder to gain such rating in 2000
then it is
for example in 2019 because there's just
more rating today at the top so you you
know you win more points if you win a
game and it was just much harder in the
year 2000 but even more impressive if
you look at the 20th 20th place it's
Bobby Fischer and Bobby Fischer achieved
the rating of twenty seven hundred and
eighty nine point seven on 4th of August
1972 so almost 50 years ago and it was
insane having saturating in those days
because no one was even close so this is
just is just insane that Bobby Fischer
that achieved this rating in 1972 is
still in the top 20
you know chess players ever because if
you if you look at all the other names
these are modern chess players ok
aside from Kasparov and kramnik now or
no one else is retired from this list
which is just OK and Karpov but all the
other guys are still active players so
it's really really insane now but I just
wanted to show this to you if you're
interested I don't know maybe you
haven't seen it but there it is but yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you've enjoyed my short
coverage of the creation Grantchester
being played in zagreb so I really hope
you like that I would like to thank
Michael Bogert Benedict Friedel Trevor
Edwards best of all comma and Tom summer
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
and I would also like to wish a very
happy birthday to owen Lloyd who I hear
is an amazing husband and a fantastic
that dead two two teenage boys
so he's 50 years old today and I really
hope you had a you know great
celebration and that you will win you
know a lot of games in the days to come
so really really have a good one so yeah
that's it I do hope you enjoyed it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon checking up in your
suggestions and most likely as of
tomorrow we are continuing the
Capablanca saga thank you all I will
soon have an excellent the rest of your
day